[Applause]
- So Fresh Off the Boat, Crazy
Rich Asians and Hustlers.
- Hustlers, yeah.
- Like these are, I love
that you're just like,
the scope of what you could
possibly do like acting-wise,
- Yeah.
- Like you're a stripper,
you're like all these.
So, did you study for that?
Like do you have to, cause
I know that a lot of actors
like really get into
the roles and wanna know
and be able to portray
the character properly.
- Yeah.
- Did you do that for all of them?
- Oh yeah Fresh Off the Boat,
I had three boys, just uh-
[Laughing]
I had all these babies, no not really
but I did, I did work at a strip club
To get ready for Hustlers.
- [Kelly] You did?
- I went undercover
- What did you have to do?
Did you strip?
- [Constance] I gave
lap dances to strangers.
- [Kelly] You're lying
- [Constance] I am not lying!
- You're not lying! You're not lying.
- I made six hundred bucks my first night.
- Oh my God, I love you.
[Applause]
- Beautiful and-- (crowd
cheering drowns out speaker)
- I did.
- Oh my gosh, I thought
you were being funny.
- I was not being funny.
- You are so method.
- And it was not funny.
- On my, it was not.
No
- [Constance] No.
And I was just, you know I put
like fake tattoos on my neck
and I like changed my hair, like
I put like you know these hair pieces in.
- You get to be like another person.
- Yup.
- That's awesome.
- Or you, who knows?
I don't know.
- Yeah, maybe I found my real
self there in the strip club.
- [Kelly] No but that's awesome,
you really went like for it
and that's probably why
you pull it off so well
in the theater like in the movie.
- Oh well, I mean, I think a big part of
I guess pulling it off is
having a great team around you.
And I think working with
Jennifer and the girls.
- Yeah.
- [Constance] I mean we
really loved each other and--
- Yeah, she's really kind.
- Oh she's the best.
And so I think that's really
what made the movie for me.
I mean the stripping helped me to know
(audience laughing)
that feeling.
- 'Cause you know you can't duplicate it.
The first time you walk
into a club and say,
"Hey I would like to have a job here."
And then you go work that night.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Did you do the pole thing?
'Cause I actually tried
doing it once there was--
- It's hard
- We are not weirdos my family,
but there is it was like,
we were all at like, some
I don't even know where it
was, some hotel around Vegas
we all went for like New Year's Eve.
And there happened to be a
pole in the middle of the room.
We're like, "What freaky things
have happened in this room?"
- (laughing)
- [Kelly] And then we all tried,
and I about broke everything.
(audience laughing)
Like it turns out, it's really
super athletic and hard.
- It is really hard.
I installed a stripper pole--
- When you're drunk though
you think you can do anything.
- Oh right yeah, and when your naked
they don't care if you're that good.
(audience laughing)
- That depends on the kind of naked.
- Hey, there's someone for everyone.
- Okay, okay.
- That's the another thing
you learn from workin'.
But I installed a stripper
pole in my living room--
- [Kelly] Wow.
- For a few months.
- Wait are you, with someone?
'Cause they're excited if
you-- (bursts into laughter)
- Yes.
- My husband would be like, "Yes!"
He would be like so excited.
(audience laughing)